la vaccination bat son plein au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 2000
vaccins ils sont administrés chaque jour
en moyenne
vendredi 16 avril le président du sénat
gérard larcher est venu témoigner de
cette forte activité aux côtés des élus
locaux
c'est comme une start-up corps été créé
en quelques mois et je veux dire c'est
une réussite pour l'instant il ya un
moral des troupes très fort les gens qui
ont qui sont dans l'équipe ont un
sentiment d'appartenance très fort de
voir avant de sauver des gens qu'en
trois mois le vaccinodromes a injecté
plus de 45000 vaccin kaiser au modern
art il faut maintenant que nous les
parlementaires qui contrôlons l'état qui
votons les lois nous ressentions bien
les attentes attentes en termes bien sûr
de doses vaccinales et puis ici la
volonté un peu particulière d'assurer
une étude épidémiologique
cette étude vise à surveiller l'immunité
des vaccinés la protection des vaccins
varie entre 6 mois et un an selon les
personnes objectif mieux appréhender les
délais d'immunité ce projet sur cent
mille personnes dans un territoire n'y a
pas beaucoup d'endroits nous connaissons
d'autres propositions mais celle ci elle
est particulièrement importante par
l'étendue de cette étude le vélodrome
entrera bientôt dans une nouvelle phase
les quelques 400 personnels déployés
pour assurer ce rythme on risque encore
d'augmenter
après le premier mais en tout cas on va
entrer dans une
meilleures livraisons de vaccins et là
on va pouvoir effectivement monté si
bien entendu le ministre à la santé une
demande un rythme en augmentation
constante qui pourrait aller jusqu'à dix
mille injections par jour